und vielleicht kurz noch mal die gründe
nennen warum es diesen alex w wie ich
ihnen jetzt so vier jahre präsentiert
habe halt bei quatsch unterhaltung
blabla nicht mehr so geben wird das ding
ist ich kann ich das gern mal zeigen
einen kanal hat eine extrem gute cpm
die lag jetzt im dezember weil leute
also hier ich habe jetzt letzten 30
tagen ausgewählt
[Musik]
jetzt bitte nicht lachen
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen bayern mein video
meine stimme ist leicht weg aber
wirklich nur ganz ganz leicht hatte ich
auch wirklich schon ewig nicht mehr
seit gestern also seit neujahr ich bin
so aufgewacht und ich konnte eigentlich
gar nicht mehr reden mittlerweile geht
es wieder um ich wollte das video schon
gestern aufnehmen ging halt ich es
vielleicht auch mal ganz lustig ich
hoffe ihr nehmt mir das nicht übel also
heute müsst ihr mich leider so ertragen
trotzdem würde mich sehr freuen und wenn
ihr das video bis zum ende schaut weil
es wirklich ein sehr sehr wichtiges
video ist dann halt für mich in dieses
jahr 2019 zu starten und um vielleicht
erstmal auf den titel einzugehen ich
glaube ich nenne das irgendwie das ende
von alex wie oder soja und was es damit
auf sich hat das würde ich euch heute
gern mal erklären ich habe mir gar keine
notizen gemacht alles ist einfach nur in
meinem kopf und am würde gerne mit euch
ein bisschen darüber reden wie es jetzt
2009/10 für mich weitergeht weil sich
einiges ändern wird so ich fange einfach
mal an und zwar jetzt schon seit
bestimmt vier jahren aktiv youtube wenn
nicht sogar viereinhalb jahre und ich
habe damals angefangen weil ich mir sehr
viel spaß gemacht hat einfach videos zu
machen und ich habe immer das gemacht
weil wir lust hab hab s einfach
hochgeladen und ja so ein wirkliches
konzept das sich jetzt nur dass oder das
mache hatte ich nie und das war mir auch
egal einfach weil dieser spaß im
vordergrund stand und alles was mir so
in den kopf gekommen ist habe ich halt
einfach umgesetzt und die meisten von
euch kennen mich ja wahrscheinlich auch
nur so als quatsch typ lara backe wie
man es auch immer nennen möchte und das
ist halt so da kann man auch nichts dran
ändern
das ding
ich baue eingehen was kurz für mein hals
naja egal wer eigentlich nicht schlecht
denke ich nach dem video das ding ist
als ich damals angefangen habe war ich
15 oder so und man wird halt auch alter
und entwickelt sich und ich bin das kann
ich jetzt mal vorweg sagen für das alles
so so dankbar dass ich halt meinen
youtube kanal habe dass ich den so
aufgebaut hat wollte jahre und dass ich
mir um ganz ganz viele dinge überhaupt
gar keine sorgen machen muss
ja und das ist natürlich nicht
selbstverständlich und da bin ich in
einer sehr glücklichen position trotzdem
bin ich sehr sehr wichtig auch
irgendwann einmal vielleicht so ein
kleinen abschluss zu finden und mal an
sich zu denken und anders zu denken was
man wirklich machen möchte so leute und
jetzt muss ich auch mal auf den punkt
kommen
youtube ist so riesig geworden es kommen
tagtäglich neue nutzer dazu die videos
hochladen und es gibt soviel quatsch das
ist wirklich heftig und ich weiß nicht
ich bin schon die mehrere jahre dabei
wie sich das entwickelt hat das hätte
ich niemals so gedacht und für mich ist
es ganz ganz wichtig jetzt mal zu sagen
hey ich möchte mich jetzt mal von diesem
ganzen content so ein bisschen abheben
und einfach das machen wo ich am meisten
lust drauf hat und wo ich auch noch in
drei vier jahren sagen kann
das macht mir richtig spaß das kannst du
noch weitermachen natürlich machen wir
so videos wie einen ganzen automaten
leer kaufen und selbst viel spaß es ist
lustig trotzdem sind das so sachen wo
ich dann weniger hinter stehe also
sachen wo ich zum beispiel sachen
ausprobiere produkte testet wie ist ja
am ende des letzten jahres ganz ganz
viel gemacht ganz ganz wichtig zu sagen
natürlich möchte hier auch weiterhin
noch so unterhaltungs videos machen wo
ich einfach irgendein quatsch machen
allerdings nicht mehr so als hauptfokus
da möchte ich nämlich jetzt er den fokus
auf andere sachen ich bin anfang des
letzten jahres auch so onlineshop videos
gekommen wie amazon wish und so weiter
und habe das auch immer weitere mario
merz am ende letzten jahres gab es ja
die wache wo ich tagtäglich so ein video
hochgeladen habe wohl irgendwas getestet
habe und das ist halt so der content den
viele mittlerweile sogar mit mir in
verbindung bringt er mir selber
unfassbar viel spaß macht und furcht
sagen kann dass da stehe ich total
hinter und
möchte ich gerne auch noch in drei oder
vier jahren machen das vierte ist sowas
gibt es nicht wirklich in deutschland
ein typ der sich hinsetzt und produkte
vorstellen natürlich und ein typ der
sich hinsetzt und irgendeinen quatsch
bestellt den halter auspackt und das
ganze in eigentlich eher im
unterhaltungs video präsentiert so
möchte ich das zumindest machen und das
ist so die hauptaufgabe die ich mir für
2009/10 jetzt mal als ziel gesetzt habt
einfach mal was neues auszuprobieren
weil das ist glaube ich sehr sehr
wichtig dass halt einfach jetzt mal zu
tun für mich um wieder ja wie soll ich
sagen einfach um mehrheit seine neue
aufgabe zu setzen weil das andere
keine ahnung ich habe jetzt zwar noch
nicht die millionen erreicht die aber
relativ kurz davor und es gibt nichts
was mich jetzt noch reizt so krass daran
weiter zu arbeiten auch wenn natürlich
diese unterhaltungs videos vermutlich
mehr klicks machen als diese
produktvideos möchte ich trotzdem jetzt
einfach mal für mich sagen es ist egal
du machst einfach das wo du richtig für
brands und hofft dass ihr alle
damit geht und natürlich auch noch ganz
ganz viele andere leute auch ältere
leute sich so etwas anschauen weil das
sehe ich ganz stark bei diesen wunsch
videos amazon videos irgendein china
schrott videos dass unter den zuschauern
halt auch sehr viele ältere leute sind
was mich sehr freut und das finde ich
auch ganz ganz wichtig einfach bei
youtube auch immer mehr von älteren
leuten genutzt wird heute ihr glaubt
nicht an struck das wissen mit dieser
stimme die ganze zeit zu sprechen
auf jeden fall an die jetzt ein bisschen
traurig sein und sagen hey das
unterhaltungs videos wünsche ich mir
aber schwer zeit wird das nicht traurig
das kommt auch noch allerdings nicht
mehr so viel
ok bevor ich jetzt aber ganz ganz
wichtig hat noch eine zweite sache auf
die ich mich auch sehr freuen
es ist nicht mal eine erkältung ich habe
mal gesagt livestreams das ist nichts
für mich
also habe ich sehr oft gesagt und ich
habe mir in letzter zeit öfter mal so
leicht für uns angeschaut und ich habe
mir gedacht hey du probierst du das
nicht einfach mal aus hat mich zwei drei
mal die woche abends hin zu setzen für
eine stunde und einfach mal live stream
ich bin kein gamer einfach live stream
schaue mir videos
ganz entspannt für die leute die abends
auch nie wissen was sie machen sollen
schaut mir dann gerne zu ich hab mir
nämlich einen zweiten kanal gemacht da
habe ich sehr lange überlegt wie ich
denn dann nennen möchte
eigentlich wollte ich den alex faunen
also alex v wenn jetzt allerdings auf
den namen alex wir bekommen einfach weil
das ich weiß auch nicht
schaut euch den kalorien man ich habe
schon ein profilbild erstellt das sieht
so aus und ein titelbild das sieht so
aus und da gibt es jetzt halt zwei drei
mal die woche abends und livestream wo
ich mir irgendwas anschaue und da werden
auch weitere kleine uploads folgen
also es ist nicht super super freuen
wenn ihr sagt hey habe ich bock drauf
abonniert gerne den kanal und dann
starten wieder direkt war vielleicht
schon heute abend den kleinen live
stream also würde ich mich wirklich sehr
darüber freuen wenn ihr jetzt drüber
geht das ganze in der beschreibung und
einfach mal kurz ein abo dallas hätte
was geht
diesen part muss jetzt leider noch mal
aufnehmen ein mikrofon kipling
vielleicht den geist auf und die hälfte
konnte man nicht hören um das ganze
jetzt abzurunden
damit ist bestmöglich versteht ich
möchte da auch ehrlich sein und
vielleicht kurz noch mal die gründe
nennen warum es die sind alex w wie ich
ihnen jetzt so viele jahre präsentiert
habe halt war quatsch unterhaltung
blabla nicht mehr so geben wird das war
für mich letztes jahr oft nicht so
leicht wenn man halt zur uni geht
und nebenbei youtube als
haupteinnahmequelle rat erhalten gutes
mittelding zu finden weil natürlich auch
mit diesem eigenständigen leben hohe
ausgaben in verbindung stehen und dann
immer noch 450 ist die woche zu bringen
war für mich schon oft sehr anstrengend
wie hat ja auch so ein bisschen stress
probleme weswegen ich mich jetzt auch
einfach für diesen weg entscheiden
und das machen möchte was mir am meisten
spaß macht das dann aber auch natürlich
bestmöglich zu machen
aber halt nicht so viel das ding ist ich
kann euch das gern mal zeigen einen
kanal hat eine extrem gute cpm
sie lag im dezember bei über 5 euro oder
5 dollar
auch im november bei 4 dollar und das
ermöglicht mir einfach zu sagen ey du
musst nicht so viel machen und trotzdem
gut davon leben zu können leute also
hier ich habe jetzt letzten 30 tage
ausgewählt und ich hatte in den letzten
ntbm von fünf dollar und 13 cent was für
videos die unter unterhaltung gelistet
sind mehr als gutes wenn ich jetzt
meinen anderen vergleiche also das ist
wirklich extrem stark und das entstand
natürlich nur durch diese ganzen
produktvideos man ja ganz klar sehen
auch wenn ich die einnahmen mit den vom
letzten jahr zum beispiel vergleiche
dass das nochmal extrem gestiegen ist
und ich glaube das ist für ihn
nachvollziehbar wenn ich jetzt sage dass
mir so produktvideos am meisten spaß
machen und ich da half selbst wenn ich
weniger mache ja genug geld verdienen um
eine uni zu bezahlen um die wohnung zu
bezahlen und so weiter dass ich mich
halt mehr darauf fokussieren
natürlich nicht nur aber viel mehr als
früher jetzt habe ich euch einfach mal
meine ein haben so ein bisschen gezeigt
aber es hat sich jetzt einmal angeboten
ich mein ich habe die einnahmen ja auch
nur durch euch deswegen ja hier also
leute das war jetzt einfach mal so ein
bisschen wie talk so ehrlich wie möglich
und so ist das also abonniert sehr sehr
gerne mein leibchen kanal alex w und auf
diesem kanal sehen wir uns die tage
wieder
ich muss mir erst mal gedanken noch
machen und dann wird 2019
ich muss erst mal wieder gesund werden
also danke für den ganzen support über
die jahre und jetzt ist einfach zeit für
eine kleine änderung ich hoffe ihr
versteht das
haut rein ich trinke jetzt ein t